-There's a lot going on
right now.
People are still stressed
about the election,
and I think we could all use a
break, so right now we'd like to
show you some uplifting,
creative videos,
whether they come from
quarantine
or just stuff from
around the country.
It's time for "What Are You
Doing Wednesday?"
♪ -What are you doing
next Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you doing
-First up...
[ Laughs ]
This is good. I've never seen
a cat relax like this.
Check this out.
♪♪
He's on his back.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that.
Yeah, I tell ya.
[ Applause ]
I've never seen a cat
on his back like that, man.
That looks like me three days
into my vacation in Mexico.
[ Laughter ]
Actually it looks like me
20 minutes into my vacation
in Mexico.
Next up, this toucan
was hoping to have
some of its owner's breakfast
but ran into some trouble.
Watch this.
-You're actually not allowed
to have doughnuts.
No.
[ Laughter ]
You're not allowed
to have doughnuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, so...
[ Applause ]
Froot Loops, yes, doughnuts, no?
[ Laughter ]
What are the rules?!
Tell me the rules.
Next up, Halloween may be over,
but this woman
seems to like scaring
her husband year-round.
Watch this.
[ Car alarm blaring ]
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
The husband was like,
"Well, someone's horny."
[ Laughter and groaning ]
What? Car horny!
What are the rules?!
[ Laughter ]
What are the rules?
And finally, this bulldog...
[ Laughs ]
I just like this.
This bulldog just wanted to
relax on his hammock.
That doesn't make any sense,
but anyways.
The bulldog just wanted to relax
on a hammock,
but luck wasn't on his side.
Just check out this guy.
Come on, buddy. Come on, bud.
Come on, bud! Whoa! Nope.
♪♪
There he goes. Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
That was "What Are You Doing
Wednesdays?"